- What I always say
is I'd like to hire a neurologist
to study people watching animation.
I'd love to find out what
parts of the brain light up.
(bright upbeat music)
- We're so glad, first of all,
to be able to make the show.
And our first goal was
to not ruin the TV show.
We wanted to make a
movie only if we could do
a good job on both
things at the same time.
Then the next goal was to make something
that could truly be a movie.
We love making a TV show,
we feel very lucky to be able to do that.
It's a unique thing to make a TV show
that's lasted this long.
You really know the fans really have
a relationship with those characters.
That's a long relationship, some of
those fans have been
watching the whole time.
However, all of us that work
on the show love movies.
And it was very exciting
to be able to make one.
I have never had the pleasure
and I may never again.
The fact that it's an adaptation
of an existing television show had
to be both our everyday reality
and also something that we almost tried
to ignore at the same time.
We had to make it a
movie that slots right in
to the TV show and leaves
no fans disappointed
and hopefully drop some
right back where they were.
They can pick up and watch season 12 after
they finished the movie but we also had
to make a movie that could
live without the TV show.
If there's somebody out
there who hasn't seen
the show and walks into the theater,
I want them to have the feeling like,
"Holy crap, what a good movie!"
And they may or may not wanna go watch
the TV show after that and
that is absolutely fine.
We wanted to service that person too.
(upbeat music)
- One of the pitfalls
that we thought would be there, temptation
when you wanna go bigger with the story,
one urge is to make your world bigger.
And we didn't want to get tempted by that.
We made it a little bigger here and there.
We pushed out at the seams a little bit,
but what we ended up trying
to do instead was make it deeper.
We wanted to take the same
locations you've already seen
and tell you something you
didn't know about that spot.
The same people you already knew
and tell you something you
didn't know about them.
We knew it, we wanted to it to be
a mystery because we love that genre.
And we knew it would give us the stakes,
the higher stakes, we knew
we wanted to have music
because we knew it would
help us with spectacle.
And we knew that we wanted to have
these action set pieces
because of the same thing.
It would fill the screen and make
the audience feel like they got something
for their money that was worth leaving
the house to come see this thing.
And I think the part that
we worked the hardest on,
was figuring out something that was there
in the show all along, but
we hadn't explored yet.
You are really having to dig
and root around like
some truffle pig, trying
to find that story that somehow,
you haven't found up until that point.
That was the real work,
cause can we make this story true
to the show, make it
true to the characters,
but it's emotional stuff that
we haven't explored before.
We love our crew, we have a great group
in many, many, many,
many, many departments.
We are talking about people who've been
there since the very beginning.
Bernard is one of those people.
He boarded on season one from
Australia, Bernard DeRman
and then we enticed him
to come join the crew.
And then we further enticed
him to become a director.
So he was the perfect
person to direct this movie.
We then added very carefully, mostly
we took our folks from the series and gave
them roles on the film, but
we did add a few people.
And I think it's worth highlighting
our art director, Ruben Hickman,
because he wasn't on the series with us.
He came from a movie background.
Ultimately we feel, even though none
of us had made a movie before, we all felt
at least we're experts on Bob's.
But what Ruben did that
kind of made us all sit up
a little higher in our
seats that every meeting
was he brought light in a way to
the backgrounds, especially but really to
the whole movie it just
suddenly was infused
with this kind of emotion
that was waiting to be drawn out.
But it just hadn't quite been lit yet.
What I always like to say it was like
we got Edward Hopper to come in
and paint the backgrounds of Bob's.
(gentle music)
I love animation, I've only ever worked
in animation before
that, I was bartending.
I've never aspired to work in live action.
I love live action and I watch a lot of it
but I don't need to tell
stories in that medium.
I like this medium and movies are special.
They really are, TV's wonderful.
And I love making a TV
show but movies have
this possibility of being elevated.
First of all, you're gonna go sit
with a bunch of other people.
You're gonna sit in
the dark and experience
that thing that can only happen
in a room with other people.
And that's just part of being human.
And then animation is weird, I think
it enters the brain in a different way.
I think 2D animation in particular is
a really beautiful medium
that has a lot going on.
What I always say is I'd like to hire
a neurologist to study
people watching animation.
I'd love to find out what parts of
the brain light up when you see Bob
and his family versus if we showed you
the same movie in live action.
I'm convinced there's some we're sneaking
in the back door of
people's minds and lighting
up different parts of the consciousness
and probably unconsciousness
because animation's
so strange, it's like a
strange little magic trick
that we we try to pull off every week.
(gentle fading music)